we need bright minds to go
into the non-profit space to go into
public service and right now
this industry one is not rewarding risk
right so it doesn't report and
reward innovation and so when young
talent graduate out
you know they're like oh where can i put
my talents where will my talents be
rewarded and they don't see that
within the non-profit space um and then
on top of that
there are so many people who can't
access this space because it is so
underpaid we as a society believe it's
not right
to pay in the nonprofit space because
that for some reason that's a sacred
area that you have to
um live in kind of a monk-like existence
and um
it's it's martyrdom smarter than him
yeah right the purity of martyrdom
which which i think is such a sad
falsehood that really holds a lot of our
organizations back and if you are top
graduate and have just killed it you
know through school you've
started some businesses and you've got a
great idea well and you're impacting
millions of lives
like why can't you be paid to do that
you know and why can't we afford the the
martyrdom trap that we really
harken back to our you know pilgrim
roots
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to yang speaks it's your
co-host
zach grauman today we're back with the
future of and it's the future of
philanthropy
the future of giving guys and something
i'm very passionate about
i used to be a philanthropy advisor he's
helped run a team called client
philanthropy solutions
so used to help some of the wealthiest
people in the world give money to
charity and i can tell you this
we are terrible at it as a country it's
one of the reasons i joined andrews
campaigns because
our society the people that were
supposed to save us who had all the
money and supposedly all the brains were
not
going to do it and it's very strange in
this country
we have no problem if you make a lot of
money
hurting people or hurting others like if
you
make a billion dollars fracking and
belting the ozone or
creating a drug like an opioid that
makes people addicted to it or
cars that are lemons or faulty brake
pads or things like that we'll still
make you a billionaire hell we'll put
you on the cover of forbes and various
magazines and put you on tv
but if you make a lot of money helping
people
we don't like you when you make a lot of
money there are so many records we fired
non-profit executives
for making too much money we have a
really twisted society so you make a lot
of money
hurting people we applaud you we make a
lot of money helping people we hate that
it's very very strange it's one of the
reasons
our philanthropic and our non-profit
system is broken
and i want to talk about it today and i
want to talk about where that industry
is going because whether we like it or
not philanthropy has to play
some form of role in how we piece
together our society specifically our
american society so
got two guests on today one is someone
who was my boss at ubs he's someone i
learned
everything i knew from when it came to
strategic philanthropy we called a
strategic giving his name is bill sutton
he has incredible hair if you're
watching on youtube
if not you're missing out so if you
listen to pod maybe check it out on
youtube but he's an incredibly
smart and thoughtful person and has seen
the world from the eyes of a lot of
these donors which is fascinating
and then we have this incredible social
entrepreneur amanda wen is on she's the
founder of rise
they're an advocacy group and she has
passed more laws than most members of
congress
um she has turned activism into actual
change and actual policy um which i
think is where the future is going and
she has a fascinating perspective being
one of the top innovators in the space
talking about the challenges talking
about the trends talking about what's
new so tune in guys the future of
philanthropy
here on yang speaks
[Music]
all right everyone welcome back to the
next episode of the future
of and today we're talking about the
future of giving
now full disclosure i have this is a
personal passion of mine
because i used to work in before i
joined andrew yang's campaign i used to
work in client philanthropy services on
wall street and my job was to help very
wealthy people
give money to charity and my biggest
learning and one of the reasons i joined
the campaign was that the wealthiest
people in the world
while many of them altruistic and trying
to help
are vastly unaware or unable to solve
some of our biggest problems
and those of us who are in philanthropy
or in social entrepreneurship or in that
space
frankly see that firsthand and i want to
take some time today to bring on some
amazing people and talk about what that
means
10 20 30 years from now what that's
gonna look like so we've got two awesome
guests the first one
is my former boss um but he's a
basically a legend in the space his name
is bill sutton he's a philanthropy
advisor but this man
has if i think i had some experience
talking the wealthiest people in the
world bill has had a plethora of that
times a hundred and seen the things
you've seen
the things you've learned the things
you've taught me uh there's nobody
better in terms of understanding the
space of bill i'm happy you're here man
happy the hair is still flowing as ever
it's beautiful um it's great to see it's
great to hear you buddy glad that you're
well and thank
thanks to the kind the kind comments of
course and there's a lot of innovators
in the space
but this woman is not just an innovator
but an accomplished
innovator in that you've taken great
ideas and innovations and turned them
into
real policy action tangible results
amanda nguyen ceo and founder of rise
amanda i'm honored to be in your
presence
thank you for being here thank you for
taking the time oh thank you
thank you so much for having me so let's
let's start let's start with the basics
here um the big question i want to ask
for both of you is like what
give me the lay of the land on how the
non-profit sector is working today
if charity's role is to fill the space
between governments and business and in
solving some of our big social
challenges
um what are we seeing
today in the landscape i think today i
mean you can't escape
um covet at 19 and you can't escape
what's happening
um what's been happening since then and
what happened before that
um as we're talking about black lives
matter uh protest
recent violence and discrimination
against minorities
asian american minorities pacific
islanders
i mean there's so much that's
interrelated there you really can't
separate that that question zach i think
from
how do we as folks who give who are
making a difference
really examine that and explore that and
and i think a number of folks
initially maybe weren't sure but it was
tremendous to see just how folks not
only
keep giving but they they give they're
giving more
and coming up with incredibly
interesting ideas i mean from the early
days of just buying gift cards from your
local restaurant
maybe that's not giving but it's giving
back in a way or maybe
it's it's going and you know buying out
uh
a month of supplies or maybe it's going
out and really taking care of the food
concerns for local health i think quick
local action
really took place in the front end and i
think that folks not only are
continuing to do that but are looking
beyond that how
how can we help the planning and
potentially helping our state and local
governments with vaccine distributions
how can we as givers do that so
for it's been such a great space for
entrepreneurial philanthropists
to make a difference either locally or
regionally or even nationally
it's just tremendous help to see those
stories it just ripple and change
and it's been such a different point of
inflection for us as a you know for
folks who give in this space
to really pause and uh and do something
new by the way that doesn't mean that
everything else
that these individuals and just folks in
general give to those needs have not
gone away
in fact right you know the they're even
the need is even more
coronavirus and this pandemic has
accelerated a lot of the problems we had
so you now
imagine the philanthropic space you now
have you have all the problems you're
trying to solve for
from a philanthropic perspective before
the pandemic and then now the pandemic
has either made some of those problems
worse or a lot of those problems worse
and you have the pandemic
cause problems or the pandemic itself
has a problem that's probably a good
question for you amanda it's
your organization rise tell us about it
it's not a covid organization but i
imagine
in this pandemic you've had a new laser
focused lens
yeah of course i mean covid has shown
very clearly that we are
as strong as the weakest among us right
so you know philanthropy your original
question was the landscape
of philanthropy of course there are
these very
well endowed old huge nonprofits right
that's existed and have done really good
work
and then we see this rise especially
aided by social media
of activists who are
well activating large communities
to channel you know their thoughts their
opinions
and i know that there's a lot of um
stigma is not the right word here
but there's this uh attitude towards
what's called
um armchair activists right where you
know you can do it from home and
but look words do matter and
because social media has essentially
democratized this access of you know
network distribution right of of stories
of empathy we're getting
different types of uh new
um new charities growing uh your
question though about rise
rise is a civil rights accelerator and
it's the first of its kind
in the world i really mean this we did
extensive research
um and it based itself
off of y combinator out of tech
accelerators lowering the barrier to
entry
right into the market and that's what
rise
does we incubate civil rights activists
by giving them
seed funding and then critically
teaching them training them
how to pass a law a lot of that has
been in rapid response to coven at least
for this year
so bill and we were talking when we were
working with clients it was
a couple things we would always say to
the client um that we worked with was
everybody is giving it's like 98 99
percent of people give to charity or
maybe it's it's high 90s usually
um not everybody's giving well and the
ex
my favorite example of not everybody
giving well was when we were doing this
bill the the ice bucket challenge had
just become a thing if you all
think back to memories um ice bucket
challenge it was for
als dump bucket ice wat ice water on
yourself you remember this and everybody
had to tag three friends
and all of our older school usually
people are giving at the end of their
life so you had older families and
generational wealth and they were asking
they would ask bill and myself they'd
say
well how do we do the ice bucket
challenge for our work right like how do
we get one of those
um and that was like the extent of like
social media or like
viral activism in the in the film fabric
space it's usually so
far behind as kovit helped accelerate
some tech innovation like have you s
are we still kind of in this old school
mentality and you have to take
you know trailblazers like amanda to
ever get anything going
i think it has accelerated a bit and i
think that folks have time now to
you know because we're home you know or
or or if we're working we're working and
then we're back home
we have more focused time it seems and
whether it's greta tunberg or whether
it's amanda or
other leaders international local i
think there's there's much more
attention and focus and i think that
people are active i mean heck
you know in my family you know my my
um philanthropic-oriented you know
daughter is very much when she has her
screen time
you know she's not just watching stuff
fun just regular stuff she's actually
reading and seeing what amanda's doing
and other folks are doing and so
are her friends and they're
communicating with each other and i
think those
rising generations are definitely
utilizing it and communicating more
and i think it's just you know
particularly because it was such a
unique time for this to happen
uh you know after and during you know
the
black lives matters protests um and
another protest
that is wrong i think it's just that
that point of confluence of everything
coming together has really created a
time where folks not just the rising
generation but other folks really
looking to social media
and i think a number of organizations
that are making change are really
getting their message out and doing a
great job with that
it's one of the things i missed because
i was not i was not
in the philanthropic advisor role when
both these things happen both the black
lives matter movement
and then obviously coronavirus like both
of these things are
massive social crises what has the
response been in your
in your world to that and both on the
cutting edge side amanda and then
i'm actually curious on like some of the
older wealthier folks too but amanda
maybe thoughts on like how you've got
started like innovating or responding to
both of those movements
the first wave at least for social
movements
especially in the 21st century is
getting the news out
right so look at what's happening look
at our people being killed right
and then the second is to have existing
structures that are there
that are accessible to create policy
change so you know the first question is
like
okay cover the story the second question
is what are we gonna do about that story
right
um and i think that the black lives
matter
activists have an incredible clear and
clear
call to action right they had very clear
ideas about
what it is that they wanted to see done
and i think that is
undoubtedly one of the reasons why they
were so successful
i agree and whether it's a someone who
can be out there in protest i mean you
immediately see what's happening
um what's happening during the protest
um
the violence that could be happening
that times i think that folks
capture that and share that and so
you're able to have immediate response
to police
reactions or overreactions in many cases
i also think that
inspires folks i mean there's a a dear
friend of ours who created this amazing
during the protest an amazing music
video
you know from that and it was a very
real very visceral piece of art
and and i think being able to build on
this very
to amanda's point is very clear call
this clarion call
where you can build on this and respond
in different ways it continues the
momentum to really help
um enhance and deepen and even broaden
the message where
everybody feels like they can be
involved and everybody actually feels
like they can make a change versus just
writing a check or giving a couple bucks
you actually
are actively part of a movement which is
very
very different
[Music]
let's face it taking trips to the post
office in a pandemic is probably
not how you want to spend your time and
that's why we recommend
mailing and shipping online at
stamps.com stamps.com
allows you to mail and ship anytime
anywhere right from your computer you
can send letters ship packages and pay a
lot less with discounted rates from usps
ups and more so it brings the service of
the u.s postal service
and ups right to your computer it's a
must-have for any business whether
you're a small
office sending out invoices maybe an
online seller shipping out orders or
even a giant
warehouse sending out thousands of
packages per day stamps.com can handle
it all with ease
and use your computer to print any of us
postage 24
7 for pretty much anything so here's the
deal stop wasting time by going to the
post office and go to stamps.com instead
there's no
risk and with our promo code yang you
get a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage
and a digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts it's lovely
stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in yang
so go to stamps.com promo code yang
stamps.com never go to the post office
again
[Music]
the largest charities in the world right
now
are banks um essentially there's
something called
um a donor advised fund where you can
instead of giving to a charity now you
can
give to or give to let's say you want to
give the red cross
instead of giving the red cross now you
put it to fidelity charitable
which has its own 501c3 you get your tax
deduction you can invest that money
and put it in the stock market it grows
it grows tax-free and then you go into
fidelity
go on their online portal and give to
the red cross or give whatever chair you
want
which theoretically is amazing because
you're going to give more over time and
you're going to this but the
the byproduct of this is that we have a
society where
the largest if you google right now the
largest juries in the world you're going
to get four or five
banks um and i'm curious for both of you
how that impacts like the donors or the
field you work in
well i think that philanthropy in
general is my experience has been
very averse and
look it makes sense if you're you know
driven by being risk averse because you
want to
you know make sure that you're advising
someone
right to make a good donation
then if you're playing it safe it's
really really hard to
get and investments into innovative
solutions so you know when it's driven
by again
uh being risk-averse and a culture that
uh is focused on less
on innovative solutions more and like
how can i make my clients happy
then it's it's hard it's just hard to to
invest in innovative things
i mean if you look at how a lot of
philanthropy dollars are even invested
um that follows amanda's you know
comment about how
philanthropy traditionally has been very
conservative
um you know i i'd like to you know
believe that that that has shifted some
and will continue to shift more i think
the bulk is is still
pretty pretty traditional which means
pretty conservative
and i think yes as more and more folks
particularly times like now really
are i'd like to think are starting or
should be thinking more of
well gosh what you know is our giving
you know can this be the seed corn for
future change
can we put something in now can we take
a big bet a big risk
here and really there's an organization
that i like that i know
that we've vetted that we've treated as
we have a r d budget for a giving
so we are going to do some evaluation
we're going to work closely with them
and let's take a big bet on this
you know i mean for folks who invested
in in zoom
or or bitcoin or tesla
let's find an organization that does
great work and let's take great risk and
maybe those this you know company
calls for change will have a similar
rate of return a three four five hundred
percent
but there's a component of risk and and
i think that more folks are maybe seeing
that
as as we are in you know where we are
now with covet 19
um and and hopefully we see more change
there i'm hopeful
uh you know we're cautiously optimistic
we're there folks start making big bets
on on amazing ideas it's so funny
because it the space i was in in the
philanthropy side there's always so much
hope um and then when i was in the the
politics
fourth industrial revolution side it was
so much despair
um but it's but i love it and i think
so one of the things that i'm really
really passionate about of the
philanthropic space is
is risk because people
don't people take plenty of risk with
their for-profit dollars
all day long um that's like what the
stock market is yet when it comes to
charity we're like hey
we don't know if that's gonna work or
it's like hey
i can't have any negative pr in my
giving
or hey like whatever the the excuses and
it's
the problem is the problem is the way
this is set up
that the people who need to take risk
are wealthy people who can give back
that it's like the individual donors
because governments can't take risks
because then
collected officials get crushed
businesses can't take that risk on
philanthropic stuff because they have to
hit their bottom line they're already
taking enough risk otherwise so it
literally is
on families to fail and try if you have
a hundred thousand if
the wealthiest folks to put that and
that's where i think a lot of innovation
needs to come from i'm in i'm curious
tell us more
we've kind of skipped over and it's like
maybe i buried the lead a bit so tell us
more about some amazing stuff you're
doing and i'll give the context of
how we got connected is not just to bill
but you were connected with evelyn with
a lot of your work on the survivor's
bill of rights which
i i can't tell you how amazing it is
because it's one thing to feel good and
talk a good game and say the right
things that is important words matter
but so do action so so for you to take
something that a lot of people are very
passionate about and turn into
legitimate policy
um frankly bipartisan policy in certain
places um
game changing and rare i'm so i'm sorry
i'm fanboying
but tell me more please no i'm so thank
you
thank you so much for saying that
because i think that
look the field of uh nonprofit industry
of activism in general of course there
are these thought leaders right who are
very important yes raising awareness
very important how do we translate these
ideas into action and
in order to do so how do we do it in a
way where we don't step on landmines
that actually hold us back there is
certainly especially when you engage in
uh legal change right like writing
legislation
you have to work with people um and
let me just tell you first of all i'm a
super nerd so my background's in
astrophysics
that really informs how i operate
and also uh with this idea
of this being larger than myself
right and having a very clear
finish line uh so what do i mean by that
um when you are able to
have a very clear goal everything else
kind of just falls to the wayside right
so if the goal
is to pass these civil rights then there
is
a very actually a simple track to that
it's you must work
in a bipartisan manner you must get x
amount of votes
right yes of course it's much harder
than what i'm saying but i've done it 33
times now
all of my laws have been bipartisan and
it literally makes rise
the most successful legislative reform
vehicle in modern u.s history
that's so impressive and so sad in some
ways it is so sad
actually literally there was this i
often don't bring up this data point
because you know people have feelings
about it but
if you look at the presidential
candidates that ran
um most of them have passed zero loss
that's average
zero zero loss we have passed i've
passed 33.
and the reason for that is well you know
we are
centered on community we're centered on
people and we also
think strategically about how to advance
these rights and how to work across the
isle
um it's so sad to say that being
able to exercise radical embassy and
then
marry that with data-driven processes is
innovative
but honestly very very few people are
doing well literally no one has a track
record so
um there's that but it's just it's
important to have a plan
and that plan being driven by what it is
that you're the change that you're
trying to make
i know that feeling where it's um i had
it with suit up a nonprofit i started
which was small scale but i had a lot
with andrew where it's like
where you're you're doing something and
you have a right message and it seems
very very rational to use like
like and i was like am i doing something
wrong because this seems really really
obvious and no one's saying
no to me and sometimes the reality is
the only way
something's going to happen the only
reason it didn't happen yet is because
no one bothered to get up and do the
work
yeah so yeah tell tell us mormon about
the work
think as if you're in like a movie about
a heist right like ocean's 11 or
something what's the first
process to get like the thing right if
you're like diamond instead of a diamond
is civil rights
you must analyze your landscape you know
you must know
what the exit points are you must know
what the rules are
if you want to win a game you have to
know the rules and then you have to know
it well enough to know
how to break the rules right so
it's so important to be educated about
the processes by which
i'm going to talk about the type of
change that rise engages in which is
creating laws right and centering it
around the communities that are affected
by it putting them
at the center so um
i can't believe you know that that's
innovative but it really is because
so much of what people feel
um especially you know reiterating the
last presidential
race is hey i don't feel like i have
agency right like i
you know my family's going through all
these issues but who's looking out for
us and also why does my voice matter
right i think that's was said in so many
different ways
and that's a real problem if we live in
a democracy that's of the people by the
people for the people
then the people need to feel like they
have a part
of this country that's working and
serving them right so
why does that happen it's happened
because there has been um
a considerable effort to i know this
sounds spicy
gaslight people into forgetting their
constitutional right to petition the
government what do i mean by that
our education most people don't know
that they could write their own law
most people don't know how a bill
becomes a law right
and all of these fundamental things are
so so important so that's what rise
justice labs
does we have a program called school of
hope
um and it literally teaches people the
blueprint for how to pass
[Music]
laws
what is life if you're not trying to
better yourself that's been one of the
hardest things pandemic is like
keeping that growth mindset and i've
found
some fascinating stuff with skill share
and skillshare sponsors this
episode yang speaks what i love about it
is that you can take classes on a whole
bunch of different
topics i've been doing more on like
entrepreneurship and just trying to
learn new specific skills so i took a
class on how to use evernote because my
notes are a disaster and evernote's
pretty cool like app
software to organize and search your
notes so you can't lose them but the
point is there's all these different
things you can learn on arts creativity
like
instagram freelancing marketing
photography all this crazy stuff
and it's this online learning community
that offers membership with meaning with
so much to explore there's actual
projects that create and support a
fellow creative which is pretty cool
so explore your creativity at
skillshare.com and get a free trial of
premium membership it's free pretty
awesome the annual subscription is less
than ten dollars a month so
it's not like super pricey compared to
some of these other crazy online classes
you can take so that's skillshare.com
you are tying all this passion and
frankly rhetoric
and a lot of things the left is good at
we are very good at drawing a line in
the sand we are very
good at saying you're on my team or not
the team
right but we are not good as democrats
excluding the past
literally just the presidential election
in 2020 we're not good at winning we're
not good at executing
and like generally speaking i'm
obviously over generalizing and
there's a lot of things you can say
about mitch mcconnell and i have a lot
of thoughts on that man
but one thing he's very good at sadly is
winning
oh yeah he gets a lot if you look at
this man's track record in terms of
supreme court justices
and impeachment trials uh one if you go
down list he wins
all the time and democrats need to start
winning because we have the right ideas
we just don't
have the right game plan one reason i
think you're the future of flank because
you've taken
all the rhetoric and all the passion and
turned it into not just activism but
organized activism where you can rally
the troops around the cot
how has that worked for you guys and
what sort of stuff have you
actually done that what have you done to
help that work so
activism to me is like straight up
voltage
right and organizing is directed energy
and what we do
is directed energy of course both are
necessary
in building movements and creating
change and
each person has their part to play in a
social movement we need the people who
are protesting we need the thought
leaders we need people who are with the
megaphones
we also need people who know the rules
right who knows what unanimous consent
is
and what redlining means all of these
things that are so important to the
actual technicality of
moving something through the existing
body that we have
right so in order for us to
actually create the change that we want
to see
one it's so basic but know
know what it is that you want and be
informed
about what it is that you want so our
first lesson right
um in in rise when you're accepted into
the program
is to do immense research right
it's when you before you ever step into
the office of a senator
have your bill draft ready right how are
they supposed to know more than you
i mean yeah i get it it's their job to
you know make the policy but also
if you want to increase your chances of
success
then tell them what it is that you want
tell them why it is it's bad that they
won't do this
and also help them see your perspective
right so that means analyzing your issue
and knowing your thing before you go in
that's really critical um hopeonomics is
actually again i'm a nerd
so it really comes back from a nerdy
place star trek people will know this
but for me the way that i teach people
hopeonomics is to envision
a four-layered chessboard it's literally
so four layers
all stacked on each other it's a game of
chess and each
layer represents a mode of thinking when
you move a chess piece on any of these
layers it affects the rest of the game
right so the first layer it goes from
most concrete to most abstract the first
layer
is mission and facts what i just said
know your issue
the second layer is narrative right how
are you gonna have that emotion
towards that the third layer is
coalition building
which is how do you work across the
aisle right and the last
layer is what i like to call the human
condition
um and honestly i actually you know
modeled this off of
graham allison's uh theory of how to
deal with dictators
in the cuban missile crisis wow okay
yeah yeah yeah but you know instead of
dictators it's for politicians it's not
you know what to think but how to think
how do you strategize right and get to
your finish line i'll tell you this from
humanity forward where andrew and i were
running an organization that was trying
to get cash relief passed we did
a lot of programs we did a lot of
testing we did all stuff and
like the best roi it wasn't even close
was we hired someone who had like very
little experience doing this
just to go harass our congressmen and
women
and that actually got the stimulus check
passed that's literally what worked
um so yes completely agree it's like and
that's a big thing andrew's like trying
to make the like
plumbing cool um which i think you're
doing really well
bill have you seen it any other
organizations like trying this
like or is this so out of left field in
the philanthropic game that
we need to spread the word high and wide
for people to start keeping up with
amanda like what's
like what are you seeing there i have
not seen anyone do it to the level of
what amanda
rise are doing at all i mean it's
i mean a lot of folks i mean you have
the image of schoolhouse rock
you know and you got a sad bill at the
top of the hill you know
and but who actually to your point zack
who actually
is is doing that who who i mean i
i grew up in tallahassee florida and
there are a ton of lawyers and a tele
lobbyist at the state capitol
and you know of course you know how
how's law passed well there's lobbyists
involved and they talk to the
the staff the local representatives the
senate
i mean it goes to the process you know i
mean that that's
that's it i mean a lot of folks don't
really know and this sounds so trite but
i i can't think of
another phrase but what amanda and her
team are doing to me they're really
democratizing democracy it's making it
so real
and and they're helping you do it and
they are helping you along the way
you have to do the work but they're
there to really help shape you do that
so
i'm not i'm i'm sure there are and meta
i'm sure has additional insight into
this but this model i think is
incredibly successful it's not just
which it's
you know there's proof and concept you
know building on amanda
and and the work that she's done um to
write so many
wrongs and and then other folks have
their
own passionate interest area too whether
they live in tallahassee or to egg
florida or wherever they live
they can make this change and they can
make it happen and being able to have
that structure
where it's just not this kind of
amorphous piece it really is i truly
believe this
you really are democratizing democracy
and that's how you make real change
[Music]
all right this podcast is brought to you
by liquid iv i had this this morning i
had the watermelon flavor
why i was tired i had a glass of wine
with dinner
i'm 33 years old and it makes me way
more hungover than i should be
so i took a little bit of water i poured
in some liquid iv mixed it all up
pounded it and i felt great this stuff
is awesome
you get more energy a little bit of
caffeine a ton of vitamins
it's just like injecting your system
with water and you don't get the crash
like you do
when you're hammering yourself with
coffee or things like that so there's
matcha in there
ginger there's all this amazing
antioxidants that make things great
improve your mood and your focus i use
it all the time specifically today
before recording this so grab your
energy liquid iv in bulk
nationwide at costco heyo love costco or
get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com and use
code yang y amg as you know
at checkout that's 25 off anything
when you use your promo code yang
liquidiv.com so start fueling your
adventure today
liquidity.com promo code yang
[Music]
besides money um what's the biggest
obstacle to getting this done getting
this scale
getting this um more streamlined things
like that
ego
[Laughter]
um no look uh you said it earlier
how do we make plumbing cool there's a
difference between feeling good
and doing good and there is a whole
group of people
who you know are engaged in activism
maybe
they were well intentioned when they
started right but
uh along the way i've been more
concerned about
fame and you know i think it's so
so important for everyone but also
for philanthropists to understand that
change
sustainable change needs to be
not only flashy moments right zeitgeist
moments but also
the moments in between okay and that
doesn't look
so flashy and glamorous all the time so
you know in investing in things like
structural education you know
the rise teaches these you know
these tools these rules these
parliamentary procedures it's so boring
but it's so important it's so important
it has played a huge function into how
educated
our country has been about our processes
right
um and to get back to ego
look i i think that everyone should have
a level of self-esteem of course
um what i'm talking about though is how
do we
relate ourselves to our community and
how do we ask the question
you know what what do i care about and
also
what can i do for my community right
and when we start asking those questions
and seeing
ourselves not only isolated but also
living
in an ecosystem as we clearly
have seen in kovid right again we are
all interconnected here
i think that's when change can can start
to have that empathy
so we used to preach this we use bill
and i we
preaches all day so it's one of the
biggest problems in philanthropy is that
everybody wants to start their own
thing yeah and and it makes sense
because
let's most people if you're talking
about we're not talking about excessive
wealth like you retire
you've made up a little bit of a nest
egg you're looking ideally to
give back or your legacy right and
you're passionate about bone marrow
cancer you're passionate about education
whatever it is you want to start that
thing because it's your legacy but the
problem is
the world doesn't need that um because
nonprofits don't fail most startups
for-profits fail 95
fail in the first two years going wall
street journal but it's like
and bill and i always try to look up
these numbers they don't really get
reported but the irs basically has like
less than 10 of nonprofits fail their
first two years
and that's not because they're all the
epitome of
perfect capitalism or perfect non-profit
world it's because
they just exist on in perpetuity and
suck resources from each other
and the biggest piece is probably ego
bill you see this
all day long partnership is the key
where it's like hey i'm passionate about
this here's a great innovator doing it
let me help you let me
hop on bill i don't know if your
thoughts on there if you are people are
doing it more now i don't know you think
in covid and mackenzie did a report back
in
i think it was may of last 2020 um
that collaboration and partnership of
folks donors coming together to pool the
resources to engage in r d and
accelerate their giving to give more
than they have in the past
those are some of the traits of success
traits um i i've seen a lot of that
and but i've still seen folks i think
before kobe really hit
and hit hard um i would still see it
zach i mean i i
would reflect with some ceos i remember
one ceo shared you know every morning i
would wake up
thinking about how how am i gonna put
that person out of business
you know in in my business and increase
wallet share how am i
doing that and anything it's reflective
in my organization
you know my charity that that we're
working we don't do that
you know we don't have that that kind of
edge that focus i mean it's a different
kind of pace now
i mean for him that was absolutely right
but there's a number of organizations
out there i know that are hungry and
they're lean and i think there's
you know so many organizations with
ashoka or it's
you know the zuckerberg initiative and i
mean there's so many
gates and really so many more
to relay that are supporting
entrepreneurially spirited
uh folks that are making change out
there too like amanda
you know and her team and rise so i i
see an increase in that
which is great but i'll i and and
hopefully i'm seeing a little bit less
of the former
you know zach of which you shared him
i've got an idea and i'm going to make
another charity and
and it exists forever but it doesn't
make change or that
it's designed to be in perpetuity but it
never solves the problem
oh and look i say this as someone who
started his own thing like everybody
starts their own thing and um but one of
the things i did is like i went to
new york cares which is the large like i
ran a ran a volunteer organization that
um
did business competition like one day of
all corporate volunteer events for
companies um to help kids in their in
the city they're in
i went to the big volunteer organization
in new york city new york cares and i
said hey
you guys are doing park cleanups and
trash pickups and
building poorly constructed houses with
accountants from kpmg and they're all
bad builders and that's not a fun event
and you're
you're sending care boxes to veterans in
iraq which is very wholesome but there's
a million organizations that do that and
you are
building it from scratch you don't even
know where to send the packages like
um i can help here we have a great
organization of infrastructure you have
a ton of corporate clients
i don't even care about the money like
i'm just happy to like let's partner
whatever however you want we'll do it
and they
were like no thank you peace out see you
later um
that's the game and it's like the
analogy amanda is like someone's like
really passionate about what you're
passionate about
and instead of plugging into your
infrastructure that's already past 33
laws
going out and trying to raise money to
do their own thing their own way
have any has anyone tried to partner
with you like are there a lot of
non-profits or
lobbyist firms or things like that that
that can partner with you what have you
seen
i think um i mean yeah i'm really
grateful to the people who have reached
out
um and in good faith i
your story really resonates because when
i started rise i literally
went to existing places and i was like
hi i want to be an astronaut like i just
want my civil rights and
um can you help me uh and we got turned
away
hey like that's how rice started because
people were like look
cool i sympathize but also
and like it came from a realistic place
i don't have a bandwidth for this now or
like you know we're fighting for our own
things we can't help you for this and
then we succeeded
then we got people coming out those same
very people that i went to
and they said hey wait a second why are
you on our turf literally
quote um well they weren't so nice about
saying that so
that's actually a little watered down
but
um it was unbelievable we were like uh
you know
yes we did here's the email um
but yeah i i look there are
every single industry nonprofit any
single
type of community always has turf and
issues
like that but as long as i think you
are smart about how you do it and you're
actually addressing a need and that need
isn't like
to satisfy your own ego but rather like
people are really calling for it right
it's coming from the community who are
you serving and
exactly what kind of change are you
trying to create
like what are your metrics and how are
you holding yourself accountable
every single week our team
no matter where you are from calls and
we call it a leadership call and we
literally report on our metrics
right so this year we've introduced this
amount of bills that has passed this
committee and we have served how many
people
and every single campaigner reports in
from
their state from their country the
campaign stats
um and it's not only because like we're
obsessed with
collecting data if you make a difference
in alaska it will inspire people in
alabama
to feel a little less alone and that's
really community is really really
important especially when you're engaged
in really hard work that
can be traumatic and um having
a very clear call to action having
metrics having bite-sizeable goals so
you can see a return on investment of
your energy
and having a clear finish line all of
these things help
create momentum not only for the
movement but for yourself too
i love how that that really kind of does
away with the tur hopefully anyway
you know continues to do away with some
of those turf no absolutely
and thank you for saying that one of the
most heartwarming things i've been
watching at least in this past
accelerator cohort how people have
worked with each other across issues
there's a lot of cross-pollination
right so for instance the most common
you know committee
assignment is judiciary if you're
working on civil rights issues it's the
same senators you're going to be
testifying in front of
right and so um you don't have to like
recreate the wheel every single time
you can absolutely teach each other you
know how to testify
and and we've seen that um and i think
that
also that's where innovation comes in
right when we're able to collaborate
instead of you know this is my part of
the pie you stay in yours
[Music]
all right i just got my new and i've
said this before so i've got my second
new
helix mattress because i like the first
one got another one
helix matches are like sleeping on the
pillow
if you will like a massive pillow
they're so freaking comfortable and i
got a king so it's like
literally swimming in it so you go
online you take a two minute quiz talk
about how you sleep which way you sleep
on your back on your side
and then you find a mattress that they
have that works for
you and it's so awesome but you don't
take my word for it because
helix was aborted number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020
by gq and wired magazine if you go to
helix.com
yang take their two minute sleep quiz
they'll match you to a customized
mattress and give you the best sleep of
your life i can say that with
authority because i love my mattress
they have a 10 year warranty
you get to try it out for 100 nights
it's totally risk free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it so here's the deal helix
is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com that's helix h e l i x
sleep.com slashing for up to 200
off and two free pillows
[Music]
so to me you study the history of
philanthropy in the history of giving
um it's back it's it's human nature to
give back in in many ways and and really
and i said this in the beginning episode
philanthropy was essentially this like
gap essentially
filling the gap between the problems
government couldn't solve
and the problems that businesses were
either creating or just them or
didn't touch either right so it fell
between these two the future of
philanthropy
seems like instead of that being a gap
it's almost like with government
is failing philanthropy is not just
filling the gap but it's starting to
replace
or in impact or accelerate
government work more so than i've ever
seen and it's even probably you could
probably make the argument for the
business side too in terms of making
companies be more responsible well
like i'm curious you guys thoughts where
is the philanthropic space going
there's a quote i'm not gonna get it
right but essentially
uh it says the brightest minds of our
generation
are helping tech companies figure out
how people can click on ads instead of
solving the world's most pressing
problems
we need bright minds to go
into the non-profit space to go into
public service and right now
this industry one is not rewarding risk
right so it doesn't report and
reward innovation and so when young
talent graduate
out you know they're like oh where can i
put my talents where will my talents be
rewarded and they don't see that
within the non-profit space um and then
on top of that
there are so many people who can't
access this space because it is so
underpaid right so especially public
service
um or just non-profit in general and
people have
uh a lot of college debt to worry about
people have
lives to live right and so so many of my
peers at least i saw
graduate harvard and were like you know
what like i care about xyz issues but
i'm going to go into
xyz you know fields that maybe i don't
really want to but
i want to gather up you know this kind
of um
security belt before i can jump into
something else
right but when you do that essentially
you're saying okay i'm going to devote
my talent not into saving the world at
this moment though i have the talent and
i have ideas
but i'm going to do it for something
else um
so we're losing we're losing generations
of talent
that are so so needed because the world
is literally like on fire
um and i think philanthropy can
absolutely
help with creating these spaces um
you know you said it earlier zach when
you're like you know a lot of people are
willing to take risks for
profit um and i think that absolutely
should be a new way a new lens
um if giving in to finance would be dan
palotta
has a fascinating ted talk on this it's
called uncharitable if you guys want to
google that maybe i'll put the link in
but i'm bill we've had him to speak but
i know you have a ton of thoughts on
this bill but basically how broken
one like a lot of people think you get
the social value of working in a charity
but the reality is if you're working for
apple making the health app
or whatever like whatever tech company
you're getting some social value working
there too
in fact you can make more money and
donate to nonprofits you like to and
that feels great
so bill um thoughts on
the future of philanthropy and frankly
how this like the compensation piece or
the incentive piece is broken what do
you think
i i think you and amanda i mean are
are spot on on this thought and dan
um really has created a a movement and
treatable is a great a great one i think
it's one of the most watched
you know ted talks everybody's watching
yeah just very powerful in it because i
think so because it strikes a chord i
mean if
you're that apple you know young apple
just got your mba and
you're doing really well and you donate
a quarter of your salary you know when
you pick a charity most likely you are
the top donor to that organization or
could be put your name on the building
after you get named
all right exactly that gets you the name
of the building but what they don't have
is someone who um with the same skills
and talents that that you have
coming out of the mba program and
applying it for change
because there's this long standing and i
and dan obviously
is much better than i ever could um so
i'm not gonna
go there but it's just the fact that you
know the way that we treat
um how organizations how it's not right
how we as a society believe it's not
right
to pay in the nonprofit space because
that for some reason that's a sacred
area that you have to um
live in a kind of a monk-like existence
it's martyrdom yeah right the purity of
martyrdom
which which i think is such a sad
falsehood that really holds a lot of our
organizations back and if you are top
graduate and have just killed it you
know through school you've started some
businesses and you've got a great idea
well and you're impacting millions of
lives like why can't you
be paid to do that you know and why
can't we afford the
the martyrdom trap that we really
hearken back to our
you know pilgrim roots uh you know
of of denying any any kind anything
that's positive or approachable out of
this i mean it's almost religious to an
extent so
i don't i'd love to see that change
obviously and i think a number of people
would
and and i think you know maybe there is
some change there with some
organizations that are
quasi philanthropic but they're really
not and whether it's you know the chan
zuckerberg initiatives
or other groups coming together that are
hiring change makers and are paying them
you know um and there's some other orgs
that are actually
you know similarly situated that are not
created as charities
but are created as different types of
organizations that can pay and
and absolutely can control that and can
hire top folks
so so maybe that's changing it a bit i'd
love to see more of that
because you do want to attract top minds
and i think rising generations whether
it's
as young as as our 10 year old or
someone who's 20 or 15 or 25 or 30 this
is such a driving factor of folks who
want to work
that are in that age range they want to
be able to
give back their idea of of making a
salary is important to them but i think
an
idea of actually making real change is
important too so i'd love to be able to
see more
more organizations embrace embrace that
that change
well if they're young they've got a lot
of debt too exactly who can afford to be
a martyr right so uh
literally it's people who have the means
to get other forms of income that can
supplement
right these jobs so when you have that
specific
demographic then being the only ones who
can afford
this kind of martyrdom then you really
limit your pool
of innovative ideas of different
perspectives and
that's why we are where we are right now
it takes a certain amount of privilege
to be able to start a non-profit
from scratch and innovate in the social
space because there's no
there's some accolades there's no real
money
which i don't mean money like let's get
rich but there's no real financial
security
which is a lot of what we all want right
um and
what happens to your point is that the
people
innovating here come from privilege
and they end up reflecting a wealthier
component
and usually more white more male or like
or
i guess the nonprofit feels it has a
good representation of women too but it
ends up reflecting a certain level of
privilege
and the people that are probably
that these organizations are literally
serving to help i imagine
their voices are not truly reflected
they just have the martyrs fighting from
them which have their own lens
self-included what excites you about how
where philanthropy's going right like
what like there's a lot of despair and i
could go all day on it but
what gives you hope i'm so hopeful i i i
really
have to be engaged in this work it's a
little
pathological optimism here but no i
really am because we are
seeing change happen and we're seeing it
in
a pace that has you know never been this
quick before
and i i think that i think president
obama has said this consistently and if
you were to choose a moment in history
where you want to be alive wouldn't you
want to be alive now
right um and i think that's because we
are on the cutting edge of philanthropy
of
how we think as a society and how we
relate to one another and how we
position ourselves
and our power to create change within
this world so i'm very very hopeful
i i am also pathologically optimistic
you know
i share amanda's feelings um very much
so about that i mean when i look out and
you know and i look at you know this
amazing
picture of amplifier that amplifier art
work closely with shepard ferry um
who jeff ferry he created this amazing
piece of art you know
featuring that's the guy who created the
design the obama hope poster and a
number of other
street art um what's it innovations or
iconic images go ahead bill sorry
no no it's okay yeah the the obey crew i
mean just
andre the giant right yep and what he's
done and how he gives back
and how he partnered with amplifier art
which is a tremendous organization that
really gets that art out there
and recognizes folks like amanda and
other
rising visionaries and entrepreneurs and
really through
chef and other artists create this
amazing but i remember
you know keeping it with the family you
know maybe
a little bit ago um reno
women's march and we had fallen in love
with this work of art and amplifiers
piece then just it was the uh
uh rise and rewrite the law i think was
the
was the line on the poster referring to
amanda and the work that ryze is doing
and we were able to to for free because
this is amplifier's mission
uh which they get into schools by the
way i mean it's a tremendous way to
learn about an
um indigenous thought leaders of other
thought leaders about leaders of color
different it's extraordinary um but but
you know our daughter loved it and so we
were able to
have it printed and they marched and
held it up and through technology
somebody posted it up to amanda who
connected
and and then they connected and then her
friends connected
and i i think friend and i share that
story that optimism is
you know this is two years ago um just
how technology
if used and leveraged and harnessed
really harnessed the passion
and put that you know 4d chess board
that that amanda has
put that organization that hard work
into it i think
that's why i'm really excited because we
don't know what's happening next but
just
looking at that simple line of someone
could just see this and make a
difference and put a picture
and then and get involved and be part of
that i think that's an example of how
a very simple example of how change can
happen
and and can draw people to causes and
get them to learn more to do the work
and i think that's something we've never
really had before
and i think in the past year and a half
two years with black lives matter and
then with covert 19
is really um you know a lack of a better
word amplified that
and and i think if if folks are sent in
the right direction
and get the real real science and real
news a real process
and work with with someone like rise us
and organizations
like amanda's then they can actually
make real change happen
which i think that right we've not seen
in the past before
and that's why i'm pathologically
hopefully optimistic
no i love it and that's where to your
point bill your daughter is going to
grow up with this around her and many
kids around the country is going to grow
up
not as this oh that philanthropy do good
stuff is part of their dna
in some ways in many ways you mentioned
president obama amanda
talk about this like randomly today but
his
i think he's the second book um is
called the audacity of hope and i've
always just like like rolled off the
tongue like audacity of hope
but i like thought about that meaning
is like the audacity of having hope like
the willingness to take a bold risk
to be so bold as to have hope and
actually audacity really dive into
definitions like disrespectful
it's like like you know i can't believe
you have that
and frankly in
this time which is which is dark it's
some of the darker times we've ever been
in we're all stuck inside the world's on
fire
we don't know what to do or losing our
minds um
i am grateful for the two of you um for
having the audacity to have hope to give
us hope
and frankly from the bottom of my heart
um
to be frankly a bit of a martyr here um
like i know bill from where we were like
you turned down plenty of opportunities
to go into just the pure for-profit side
of of wall street and amanda i'm
now convinced you could probably do
anything including going to space
um but instead you're you're passing
laws that no one has the guts to pass so
um for the by my heart thank you um
amanda where can we learn more about
ryze and some of your work you're doing
yeah people can go to risenow.us slash
donate
but no if you actually have an idea
right that
you want to see turn into law and you're
a part of that community
that you're seeking to fight for please
please check out our work
um and even if you don't make it into
the cohort
uh we post all our lectures um publicly
uh so we want people to understand how
to access democracy
look to be very honest with you i want
to
be able to you know write down this
knowledge and pass it on i'm not trying
to make a buck because i want to go to
space
so um come learn do it yourself
uh and i'll see you on mars i love it my
takeaway here is the future of
philanthropy is
is is probably philanthropy doing
everything it can to solve what the
government's not doing even if that
means doing the government's job for it
um but what i want to do and the future
philanthropy is probably in
our kids in terms of how they're growing
up around this what i want to do and
i'll probably do is it 10 years from now
i'm going to invite you both back
we're going to have this conversation
all over again yank speaks we'll be at
10 million downloads a second or
whatever the heck it'll be an
international media behemoth
and we'll bring you back on to see if
we're right or wrong but from the bottom
of my heart thank you thank you the
future of giving
bill and amanda you guys are amazing
thanks thank you thank you all
bye zach bye amanda
[Music]
you